this video is brought to you by VIN
Cheryl watches what's up guys jared here
to talk about a movie that feels about
as cheerful as living in 2020 of course
i mean snowpiercer bong Joon hos 2013
film based on a 1982 French graphic
novel that might mildly haunt your
dreams unless you're really stoked about
cockroach protein bars at first glance
the film seems like a reasonable
precursor to bombs more recent grim
meditation on income inequality in
parasite but when some of the snow
starts to melt away you'll see there's
so much more than meets the eye at the
core of snowpiercer are two basic
questions one is the system we live in
inevitable and two if so what should we
do about it and also something about
ancient Roman law we'll get to that
welcome to this wisecrack edition on
Snow piercer and spoilers ahead for the
end but before we get into it I want to
give a shout out to this video sponsor
of inch arrow and Cheryl makes luxury
watches that cost less than other
premium brands their bold stylish and
handy if you just want to know the time
I got the chrono s in matte black and I
like how it makes me feel like I can
dress up any outfit just by putting it
all in it I also like that it reduces
the need for me to carry my phone around
that's the point of a watch but it's
underrated these days if inch arrow also
makes bracelets and other accessories
that could be a great gift it's great
for dads who are hard to shop for and to
personalize it you can get a custom
engraving pinch arrow has over 21,000 5
star reviews and right now they're
having a site-wide sale so you can get
up to 20% off by going up inch arrow
watches comm slash wisecrack sale or by
hitting the link in the description the
discount will be applied automatically
at checkout again that's bent arrow
watches calm slash wisecrack sale for up
to 20 percent off and now back to the
show
but first a quick recap meet snowpiercer
a world touring train that after a
global apocalypse became home to the
last remains of humanity in the most
literal caste system imaginable rich
people exist in luxury in the front of
the train while poor folks exist in
squalor in the back everyone is supposed
to worship Wilford the trains conductor
and architect who sucks
Curtis a kind of revolutionary Steve
Rogers type reluctantly leads a revolt
to take control of the train spurred on
by his mentor Gilliam a kind of more met
Nick Fury Curtis and his motley crew
embarked on a bloody journey to the
front of the Train
along the way they learned that the
Train is home to a one dopes aquarium
and sushi bar be a somewhat disturbing
nightclub and see sustainable
agriculture you know something for
everyone
finally Curtis meets Wilford who
explains that this whole revolution like
all the ones that preceded it was
planned as a means of population control
for optimum balance however there have
been times when more radical solutions
were required when the population needed
to be reduced rather drastically and
Gilliam was in on it too so don't tell
me you didn't know Gilliam and I our
plan also Wilfred who is old at this
point once Kurtis to take his place but
a tempted Curtis spots one too many
labour laws being broken and refuses he
didn't orders his comrade to blow the
whole thing up there are two survivors
the end so let's just address the Milton
Friedman shaped elephant in the room
this movie like a lot of bombs work is
very much about capitalism a group of
people was divided into the haves and
have-nots and he resistance to this
divide threatens to derail society
figuratively and literally and also
we're pretty sure the internships are
unpaid one of snowpiercer primary themes
is how inevitable and natural this cruel
system seems it even comes complete with
a whole semi religion to perpetuate
belief in itself I belong to the front
you belong to the tail when the foot
sees the place of a head the sacred line
is crust and it's not just a social
order that is treated as inescapable for
that matter wilford's perpetually moving
train is treated as the only source of
life itself it's literally the only
option
[Music]
here any alternative to the status quo
is literal suicide while trains
frequently symbolized modernity and
progress this train travels on an
endless loop making any semblance of
progress illusory it's literally just
going around in circles the
inevitability of this trains caste
system could be better understood with
scholar mark Fischer's writing on the
concept of capitalist realism as Fisher
writes capitalist realism is the
widespread sense that not only is
capitalism the only viable political and
economic system but also that it is now
impossible even to imagine a coherent
alternative to it basically it's easier
to imagine the literal apocalypse than
it is to imagine the end of capitalism
in the capitalist realist framework
there's no escaping our relentless
adherence to capitalism no matter how
brutal the effects might be if that
sounds a lot like snowpiercer scholar
Jerry canavan agrees and he wrote a
whole paper about it everything on the
train exists under the guise of
necessity those in power are merely
trying to protect the collective even if
that means brutally hammering a guy's
arm off to prove their dumb point of
course all the talk of order and
preordained roles happens a bit
differently in the real world but the
logic is the same
curtiss everyone has their preordained
position and everyone is in their place
except you that's what people in the
best place say to people in the worst
place in equality of course is necessary
for the economy to persist any tweaking
z' of the free market will cause famine
or end with gulags as Fisher puts a
capitalist realism posits that any
problem can be solved by the market much
as economists have long championed the
simple beauty of the law of supply and
demand for distributing resources those
in charge of the Train - championed the
power of balance and order in feeding
everyone population ultimately the
beauty of this so-called balance is
incredibly ironic because in order to
maintain it the wealthy must orchestrate
false revolutions as a means of
depopulating the poor just as casually
as they eat sushi twice a year to
control the fish population this is only
served twice in a year in January and
July why not enough fish Oh enough is
not the criterion
balance the system is fundamentally
unbalanced and requires extensive
intervention to maintain itself not
unlike the way real world capitalism
relies on bailouts for giant
corporations and big banks in this case
though it's the Train that is literally
too big to fail but there's more
depressing ideas to be found in
snowpiercer
consider the way life is treated in this
world 74% of the poor are killed off
without a second thought
precisely 74% of you shall die mothers
have their children taken away recruited
as slave labor life in the tale seems
hardly worth living here's where we get
into the idea of necro capitalism the
depressing sibling of necro power which
we talked about in our Mad Max video
because we apparently just love death
adjacent content necro capitalism as
conceived by scholar subrata Bobby
Banerjee is the practices of
organizational accumulation ie gaining
wealth that involve violence
dispossession and death in order for
this system to work
Banerjee explains governments must
create certain spaces of exception where
individuals do not possess rights which
is detailed section to a tee they are
subject to violent policing forbidden
from free movement and deprived of any
autonomy so what happens to humans in
spaces of exception to explain Banerjee
recalls philosophers or geo commands
analysis for the ancient Roman legal
concept of the homo soccer latin her
sacred man the homo soccer in Rome was
killable but not sacrificing in other
words they were so valueless that you
could just rant that bow to them and
leave someone fatherless but you
couldn't do so in a religiously
meaningful kind of sacrificial murder
way the point is the homo soccer doesn't
even have the benefit of being oppressed
within and by the law there's simply
outside of the law the energy in a
common point to all kinds of modern
equivalents of people living as homo
soccers a GaN band wrote of people in
concentration camps who existed in this
extra legal hell zone while Banerjee
cites the victims of imperialism and
colonization in the search for profit
the lives lost due to environmental
degradation unsafe working conditions or
resource wars are a kind of homo soccer
in snowpiercer to the tale Enders exist
in this strange outside of the law but
not really position of the home of
soccer their lives are essentially
meaningless except insofar as they can
be useful to those who actually matter
are there any
perience violinists here Wilford
selectively slaughters them like deer
but flippantly saves 18 people spare 18
to celebrate our 18th year just to show
that he can because he's a douche canoe
banerjee uses these ideas to posit that
aspects of our economy are literally
built on death and suffering whether it
be a worker who dies in a mining
accident a forest ecosystem that is
plowed away to make room for a factory
or a mercenary soldier who kills for pay
if necro power is the politics of death
necro capitalism is the economic system
of death for profit to understand
snowpiercer kanavan combines fisher's
capitalist realism with Banerjee's necro
capitalism taking the economics of death
and projecting it into the future as the
only viable outcome in a concept he
calls necro futurism or in his words
those capitalist realist anticipations
of the coming decades then anticipate
the future as a devastated world of
death you know like a world ruined by
climate change and the definitely not
idiotic idea about how to fix it as can
oven rights necro futurism positive
future that is doomed to continue modern
capitalism x' unsustainable and immoral
practices even as those practices become
more and more destructive and
self-defeating he argues that such a
vision is the dominant modern conception
of the future whereas we once imagined a
cool future with jetpacks and rad alien
sex today we can only speculate if the
2030s will out suck its 20th century
predecessor Necker futurism started
blooming in the 1970s with movies like
Soylent Green which imagines a world
ravaged by environmental destruction and
overpopulation to posit a very gross
scenario that we won't ruin for you
Soylent Green is made and at the Sheep
look up which imagines in America so
toxified by capitalist tendencies that
the air is not safe to breathe and oh
you have to pay up for some clean oxygen
each story depicts capitalism as
stupendously enduring even as it leads
to rapid death and destruction necro
futurism has become so ubiquitous now as
to be arguably the primary form of
futurism seen everywhere from wall-e -
The Hunger Games - the road to West
world - adventure time now necro
futurism is certainly vividly depicted
in snowpiercer we have the
post-apocalyptic world where in response
to
cause presumably by rampant global
capitalism 79 countries released the
artificial substance cw7 into the
atmosphere which ironically freezes the
world and kills most of humanity
this is particularly necro futuristic
here capitalist logic has destroyed the
world not once but twice but unlike
other bleak apocalypse films
snowpiercer tries to actively combat the
necro futurism of our own imaginations
rather than being a necro futuristic
film as such it's arguably a critique of
necro futurism as canikin argues life
aboard the train was not an inevitable
reality rather it was a deliberately
designed atrocity machine someone laid
the tracks someone built the Train
someone is even now driving the cars and
stoking the engine if cramming a bunch
of people into one car to subsist on
cockroach bars is inevitable it's only
because someone ie Wilfred deliberately
wasted space on an entire car of pools
or another one of saunas and whatever
the hell this one is if the kind of
order Wilfred wants is necessary it's
only because he designed it to be so the
artificiality of the world is best
demonstrated by the deliberate and
intensive system of propaganda it
necessitates as seen in the classroom
scene such propaganda and Wilfred
warship is imperative to maintaining
this arbitrary order even among those
more fortunate this brings us to the end
of the film where Kurtis has the option
of inheriting wilford's position thus
maintaining order and taking on his
supposed preordained role but he doesn't
instead he sacrifices his arm to save a
child and instructs his friend to blow a
hole in the Train which causes an
avalanche that seems to kill almost
everyone aboard but was such destruction
necessary at the beginning of the film
Curtis promises his friends that when
they take over the front of the Train
things will be different
they will rule justly and fairly will be
different when we get there having seen
what he's seen and learned that even the
Novo Gilliam is complicit in the trains
brutal architecture he appears to no
longer harbor any such hope rather in a
fitting allegory for total revolution
Curtis ultimately decides that there is
no better life to be had aboard this
train that the only Escape is to tear it
down entirely in the hopes that
something new might spring out of it and
it does two so-called train babies
survive and step on the solid land for
the
as they wander out there are two ways we
can view this one these kids are
literally screwed and potentially might
be eaten by that cue polar bear or two
they're venturing out onto untouched
snow to metaphorically construct a new
world a better more compassionate mode
of human existence so kind of hopeful
against all odds rather than merely
warning about a necro capitalist future
the film offers important lessons on
orienting revolutionaries to bong
appears to more than just a little hope
will rise up against the system he
reviles most notably the lesson that
rebelling with people of different
backgrounds and from different stations
in life is critical for a revolution to
succeed the members of the tale and our
diverse and not all of them even speak
the same language yet a translator
device allows Curtis to work with the
higher status namgoong who is fallen due
to his drug addiction similar moments of
solidarity come in our torch marathon to
the front lines where everyone men women
and children provide a valuable role in
the battle to the front this stands in
stark contrast to bongs more recent film
parasites in which members of the
working class bicker over crumbs from
their benefactors instead of working
together with these different
backgrounds come different knowledge
indeed it's clear that namgoong
understands the snow is melting because
of his past relationship with an inuit
woman like her he is convinced that the
earth is warming
later we see him preoccupied with a
single snowflake and eventually
deploying his snow knowledge to create
an avalanche and derail the Train it's
also worth noting that this cooperation
is often juxtaposed with those on the
top the train crew two used translators
but only to bark orders at the masses
and in the classroom a poster of Native
Americans is shown in the background
perhaps asking us to consider what it
means to treat a group of people as an
object of study rather than to learn
from them all of this seems quite
fitting for a film by bong joon-ho who's
often credited with forging the way for
a new transnational form of film but
what do you guys think are we being too
optimistic or is there secretly hope
embedded in this at first totally
depressing film or is everything just
awful forever let us know what you think
in the comments Mad thanks to our
incredible patrons for supporting the
podcast and our channel hit that
subscribe button and before you go I
just want to give one last shout out to
our sponsor Finch arrow if you're still
looking for a gift for Father's Day or a
nice gift to treat yourself then head on
over to Ventura watch's calm slash
wisecracks ale and you can get up to 20%
off your purchase and again thanks for
watching guys peace
[Music]